lo que pasa es que hay un problema serio
la iglesia católica que ya se está
denotando no solamente en la iglesia
francesa
eeuu austria polonia
entre otros países sin alemania aparte
han comenzado este tipo de
investigaciones debido a que se ha
sabido de estos abusos
sexuales contra niños
dentro de las reparticiones de esta
institución esto es tremendo esto es muy
muy doloroso pero muy doloroso para cada
uno de los estados y también es un
problema serio para la iglesia católica
que tiene que hacer frente a esta
situación hoy día estamos conociendo los
casos de en francia- 3.000 casos según
los antecedentes que tenemos pueden ser
más casos hay un problema de cultura hay
un problema de encubrimiento hay un
problema de un encubrimiento sistémico
hay un problema sistémico de la iglesia
católica que lamentablemente me
atrevería a plantear en los últimos 50
años aunque estudio este estudio tiene
70 en los últimos 50 años ha sido presa
de muchos jóvenes ha sido presa de
muchas víctimas menores de edad y es un
problema grave es un problema grave que
no solamente sustenta a la población
francesa sino me atrevería a plantear a
la aprobación a la población católica en
general y ahí están las
responsabilidades la pregunta quiénes
son los responsables los responsables la
iglesia la iglesia francesa los
responsables son los que cometen el
abuso obviamente o los responsables del
vaticano yo creo que acá estamos frente
a una situación de un encubrimiento
sistémico que ese es otro problema que
aquí en este informe probablemente lo
van a dar a conocer aunque se habla ya
de 3000 pederastas que es un número
bastante importante y podría ser más muy
doloroso